it's less than 2 000 kilometers from the
peace and prosperity of davos to the
devastation of ukraine
but russia's invasion has upended
european economic certainty as well as
its security
so for the elite gathered in the
rarified conference air there was a
stark message
president zielenski calling on business
and political leaders to tighten the
economic squeeze on moscow
i think such sanctions against russia
still do not exist and they should an
embargo on russian oil a complete
blockade of all russian banks all
without exception total abandonment of
the russian i.t sector and complete
cessation of trade with the aggressor
you need to set a precedent for the
complete exit of all foreign businesses
from the russian market so that your
brands are not associated with war
crimes
this was a typically well targeted
message from vladimir zelinsky to an
audience of concentrated wealth and
business power at an event typically
believes the markets are the answer to
everything well his message was that is
no longer the case there can be no
business as usual with russia and when
the war is over these companies are
going to need to help to rebuild ukraine
ukraine has brought that message in
person here too everyone does something
to bring the victory together mps whose
constituencies have been flattened want
reparations from russia to reconstruct
their country we are asking uh business
to invest into ukraine because it will
be a very you know fast-growing market
when we start the rebuilding the
infrastructure i mean you can uh just
tell me if you want to rebuild a museum
we'll find your museum to rebuild if you
want to help a school just tell us the
region we'll you know show you how many
schools were ruined in this region i
mean you can help libraries uh you can
bring you know medicine i mean whatever
you
you want we can organize
many brands have already left moscow
starbucks joining the exodus after 15
years announcing the closure of 130
stores with 2 000 employees
getting food out of ukraine is a more
urgent concern to many here 22 million
tons of grain is trapped behind russia's
black sea blockade leaving major
importers like egypt worried egypt is a
major
importer of
food and grain and especially we have
relied on grain from ukraine and from
russia and i have been speaking to my
ukrainian counterpart
the day before yesterday
and we are working to try to relieve and
release the
products commodities in ukraine for the
benefit of bringing down the prices of
of these commodities and providing them
because there is a scarcity
for egypt it is a challenge
the klitschko brothers are here too
calling for a sporting boycott of russia
ukraine fighting on every front it can
to make ultimate victory a little more
likely paul kelso sky news in davos